pâtes pains conservve et même produits
de première nécessité depuis quelques
années les distributions alimentaires
sont régulières à l'université de
versaill 50 ans en Yveline on a pas mal
de conserves et de soupe de sauce en
Boco et les produits d'hygiène ça aussi
les étudiants il prennent tous les
produits d'hygiène autant que possible
même les trucs aussi basiques le savon
le dentifrice beaucoup aussi les tampons
les serviettes euh toutes les étudiantes
qui passent prennent au moins un produit
menstruel donc ça montre qu'il y a
réellement un besoin une nécessité des
distributions d'autant plus nécessaires
que d'après l'UNEF principal syndicat
étudiant le coût de la vie étudiante a
augmenté de plus de 6 % pour l'année
universitaire
2023-2024 au niveau national aujourd'hui
c'est un/ers des étudiants qui ont faim
on sent juste un désintérêt envers la
jeunesse c'est-à-dire que là avant la la
le département des ivelines payait
l'euro restant des repas à 1 € pour les
étudiants boursiers et là c'est la fin
la situation elle est est extrêmement
alarmante et on le ressent dans le
nombre de personnes qui viennent
assister à ces distributions
alimentaires des distributions qui
représentent parfois un véritable
soulagement pour ses étudiants une fois
que tu as payé toutes tes charges et tes
factures et cetera il te reste très peu
pour te faire plaisir ou même des fois
pour manger donc faut faire des choix
donc quand il y a des il y a des
occasions comme ça faut faut les saisir
c'est arrangeant pour les produit de
première nécessité qu'on peut pas
forcément s'acheter ou qu'on doit un peu
se saigner pour acheter pendant les 3 He
de distribution une centaine d'étudiants
ont pu bénéficier des dons une situation
alarmante dont a conscience le président
de l'université ça toujours été un sujet
majeur pour pour notre université la
précarité étudiante et évidemment la
période du covid a été un fort
révélateur on a mis tous les moyens
nécessaires au-delà des moyens que nous
offrait l'état l'université a été
l'acteur principal pour soutenir et
aider les étudiants et je suis très
heureux de voir que les associations
étudiantes ou les organisations
étudiantes aussi sont acteurs une
solidarité qui va au-delà des murs de
l'université puisque l'intégralité des
denrées distribuées font l'objet de Don
extérieur